I need a favor I try not to ask too much
of you guys but tomorrow is a very
important day and I need your help
tomorrow you are going to see the
culmination of over a year's worth of
work and not just by me but by team of
over 50 talented people tomorrow at 8:00
a.m. Pacific Standard Time you are going
to see a heist with markiplier and the
favor I need is really simple all I need
from you is to be there for me that's it
just be there at the release and enjoy
the hell out of it watch it like you've
never watched anything in your life
because it's really good it is really
good I am so excited for you guys to see
this I cannot even explain how much is
waiting right around the corner of
tomorrow for you guys but the reason
that I'm asking this so seriously is a
bit more involved than the scope of what
I'm asking this is my first youtube
originals project my very first one I've
made a lot of really fancy stuff before
but this is the first one that has been
funded by YouTube and promoted by
YouTube as one of their from your shows
and even though this show is completely
free and I've made sure of that for you
guys this is still my first opportunity
to step out on a larger and more
professional stage which means that I'm
gonna be standing up there against shows
that YouTube has made already and also
shows that exist on other platforms like
Netflix at Hulu and Disney Plus and all
those other people I'm gonna be up there
with a heist with markiplier I'm going
to be happy because I could not be
prouder of what I'm bringing to that
stage I cannot wait for you guys to see
what's in store there is so much in this
monster of a show for you guys to
discover if you even remotely enjoyed a
date with markiplier you are going to
love heist you're going to love it I
can't even explain how much you're gonna
love it even the most dedicated of you
guys are probably gonna take a full week
to find your way to all 31 of the
endings
in heist but beyond you guys just
enjoying it I think that this is
honestly an opportunity the truth is the
show is different but it is the
opportunity for me to showcase what I
can do and I know there's other
platforms that are making cheesy style
stuff but this is mine this is my baby
this is the culmination of seven years
of making videos on YouTube put into one
show and I am so incredibly proud of
this and I think it stands up against
all the other stuff that you will see on
the Internet and it's free you see
there's the thing about YouTube creators
is that the world of traditional media
still doesn't give us a lot of respect
not that I demanded but they don't think
that we can actually do the things that
we're capable of they think that YouTube
among other websites and apps that you
guys enjoy and watch our fads and that
it will fade away and that you guys will
go back and watch things the way that
they have always been watched but that's
not the case this is my chance to
showcase what I can do and I am so
excited to show the world but I can't
show them and I can't prove anything to
anybody without you guys as hell
momentum is the lifeblood of every
single video on the Internet
what happens at the beginning is what
carries it through to the rest of the
world and if you guys are there from the
very beginning at 8:00 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time right there from the
get-go you will help get the ball
rolling on the thing that I'm more proud
of than anything I've ever made I mean
that literally this is the best thing
I've ever made
period so please be there tomorrow at 8
a.m. Pacific Standard Time like it like
you've never liked a video in your
entire life hit that like button like it
was talking [ __ ] about you like he just
insulted your mother share it with every
friend you've got that is within
shouting distance share it on Facebook
share it on Twitter share it on tumblr
share it on every website that has a
share button please do me this favor and
spread the word about this and make this
launch something incredible because if
it is it's gonna show the world what I
can do and also that directly affects
what I'm gonna be able to make in the
future so if you want to help me make
cool stuff down the road please do me
this favor and be there for me tomorrow
at 8 a.m. Pacific Standard Time and more
importantly above all the things that
I'm asking you enjoy I want you to enjoy
the hell out of it I want you to watch
every single one of these videos because
every single one of the dozens and
dozens of videos that you're gonna find
tomorrow is a special handcrafted
delight it's like a box of chocolates
you never know what you're gonna get and
I think you're gonna love it
I know you're gonna love it and I can't
wait for you guys to see it so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
what's tomorrow